la semaine dernière au lycée henri iv à
paris dans un des plus beaux quartiers
de la ville l'établissement accueille
l'élite
les meilleurs élèves de la capitale
issus de milieux privilégiés ce matin
ses costumes cravates et escarpins de
rigueur les élèves de prépa passe devant
un jury des oraux blancs vue des
concours parmi les jurés une
examinatrice un peu particulière en jupe
en jean elle s'appelle paul isnard
elle a 22 ans
amira ça y est vous avez tous
pauline connaît tout le monde normal
c'est une ancienne d'henri iv
pourtant elle n'est pas issue d'une
grande famille ni fils d'un riche
industriel
sa chance c'est qu'il ya quatre ans elle
a bénéficié d'un programme spécial du
lycée une classe tremplin pour les
élèves d'origine modeste comme elle une
trentaine d'autres jeunes avaient pu
intégrer cette classe un peu
particulière et pendant un an
nous les avions suivi toute la classe se
souvient encore du discours du proviseur
le jour de la rentrée on est dans les
parts de gens formidables
on est là pour faire en sorte que tous
vous soyez capable d'intégrer une de nos
classes préparatoires évidemment on va
vous demander beaucoup
tout au long de l'année nous avions
filmé pauline et ses camarades les
galères du quotidien
les soirées de révision les bonnes et
les mauvaises notes avec la classe ils
avaient aussi découvert les soirée à
l'opéra
grâce à henri iv pauline a pu intégrer
une grande école de commerce
le fcp étonnant destin pour une jeune
fille qui vient d'une famille modeste
dans un quartier hlm de montpellier sa
mère aide soignante a élevé seule ses
quatre enfants
la situation était toujours très très
facilement échapper un bon moral je le
disait toujours je vais arriver au bout
et avec des joues il fallait utiliser
fai free un steak haché de 10 en quatre
mais pas pour autant qu'ils étaient
tombés malades
d'origine camerounaise la maman de
pauline à tout miser sur l'éducation de
ses enfants
quand on interroge les frères et soeurs
les résultats sont là je passe en 10e
année d'iut de réseau
l'indication d'un frenchy je ne passais
mon bac français là et j'ai eu 15 à
l'écrit et 16 alors elle suit en
troisième j'ai sauté une grâce aussi la
grande section
mais si c'est quoi votre secret dans
cette famille où tout le monde a des
bonnes notes fait que j'assume tout le
monde est sérieux sommeil par en gros
finalement elle a fait comprendre très
tôt que c'était l'école devait permettre
de réussir plus tard et pas tout ce qui
est sorti à l'époque pauline la bosseuse
exhibait aussi volontiers son goût de la
fête
aujourd'hui elle est plus sur la réserve
elle a gagné beaucoup d'assurance aussi
ce matin par exemple elle n'hésite pas à
donner la leçon à des candidats qui ont
à peine deux ans de moins qu'elle
et on a indiqué de tu prend un air
condescendant c'est insupportable à un
moment je me suis demandé s'il n'allait
pas me lever sortir de la pièce puisque
tous les ballons je n'acceptais pas
vraiment de répondre à la question est
là presque une pointe d'arrogance dans
la voie à la mesure de son ambition sans
doute dans la foulée de son école la
jeune fille veut se présenter à l'ena
même si elle ne le crie pas haut et fort
je ne sais pas encore sincèrement je ne
sais pas du tout ce que je fais c'est
tellement monde nouveau pour moi que
pour l'instant j'essaie d'analyser un
petit peu toutes les boîtes qui me sont
proposés ensuite je choisirais donc la
voilà parmi les camarades de pauline à
henri iv
il y avait aussi geoffrey le garçon
tranquille de la classe tout droit
débarquée de sa banlieue
geoffrey un éternel optimiste pas
démonter par ses premières mauvaises
notes
le tennis est plutôt bien tout ce que
peut on commence bas puis encore
ce qui veut dire quatre ans plus tard il
n'a presque pas bougé alors toujours à
henri iv c'est ça plus ça change et plus
c'est la même chose que vous dis non
allemand là c'est ma dernière année
enfin c'est quasiment terminée toute
façon j'ai encore un mois là je vais
devoir presser d euros si tout va bien
et on voit ainsi pour ensuite j'en ai
terminé avec la prépa souvenez vous le
jour de la rentrée ses parents étaient
venus l'accompagner à la cité u tout
étonné de voir leur fils admis dans un
établissement aussi réputé vu notre
niveau social cram en même temps celui
grande majorité de français
imaginez notre fils à henri iv c'est un
bond énorme
c'est quelque chose qui est con qu'on
n'aurait pas imaginé pour ça on a du mal
à croire ou non quand a été pris a
réalisé que c'était vrai non toi le
meilleur
merci à l'époque le jeune homme n'avait
pas réalisé ce qui lui arrivait
aujourd'hui il a bien conscience que
c'était la chance de sa vie
donc on voit le recrutement de després
pas ou plus généralement des grandes
écoles c'est clair que la probabilité
que je trouve quelqu'un dont père et
cheminots et la mère employée de mairie
il ya assez peu de chance de rencontrer
des gens qui viennent de ce milieu
social là c'est vrai que
les possibilités qui me sont offertes
maintenant sont clairement nettement
meilleure que celle que j'aurais eu si
je n'étais pas passé par la cps geoffrey
vient d'apprendre qu'il va sans doute
intégrer
normale sup une grande nouvelle ils
passent les oraux à la fin du mois tous
n'ont pas connu le même parcours
voici paul audrey il ya quatre ans
c'était une des plus doués elle avait eu
son bac à 16 ans la prépa c'était pour
elle et pourtant elle n'a pas accroché
non à quoi ça sert
contre les coups de déprime elle avait
son remède vers les boutiques
j'ai dormi à minuit non ils leurs 36 je
me suis couché j'ai fini la révolution
jeu jusque là jeudi sortie aujourd'hui
et je suis tombé sur quelqu'un qui avait
envie de sponsoriser mon shopping donc
que c'était sympa mais un moment les
chaussures je digère pas assez je le
sens je vais me reconcentrer sur sac à
main ou encore aux chaussures à talons
boucles d'oreilles king size cheveux
rasés nous l'avons retrouvé il ya
quelques jours
métamorphosé 30 et au rhic trop encadré
la prépa a fini par la dégoûter elle a
préféré une filière plus classique à la
sorbonne deux ans henri iv ça lui a
suffi
j'ai vraiment on va dire une poignée du
voilà du poing sur la table les
dernières vraiment dans de bons à la
fête le temps de vraiment pouvoir qui
m'intéresse les domaines dans lesquels
ont envie de travailler qui me passionne
et ce parfois je veux m'épanouir surtout
plus tard son truc c'était la mode
désormais elle veut en faire un business
à 20 ans elle est rédactrice en chef
d'un magazine féminin sur internet dédié
à la mode africaine qu'elle a créée avec
des copines voici dernier numéro un
spécial afrique du sud
on y trouve des pages tendance des
conseils shopping des interviews de
créateurs elle n'en vit pas encore mais
c'est déjà un succès cent quarante mille
lecteurs par mois
ça m'a vraiment permis que l'on m'a dit
de me recentrer palais ni me recentrer
parce que j'allais dans tous les sens
sciences po ena école de commerce voilà
donc là au moins déjà je vois à peu près
le domaine dans lequel j'ai envie de
travailler donc
rien que pour ça ça a vraiment été fait
malgré tout l'esprit d'henri iv ne l'a
pas tout à fait abandonné depuis peu
elle s'est remis en tête de préparer des
concours d'écoles de commerce
parmi les élèves de cette classe
expérimentale la moitié à intégrer une
grande école mais surtout l'initiative
d'henri iv a fait des émules à la
rentrée prochaine
quatre autres lycées de france se
lanceront dans l'aventuré